today I'm here with boneless and he's
teaching me a brand new terraforming
Mars player how to completely dominate
at this game he's put together an over
100 slide comprehensive approach to
really doing well at this game this is
legendary tactics
alright boneless so you I can see have
poured a ton of time into this so tell
me about what what we're looking at
today
yeah today we're going to look at like a
I just came up with like a literal
recipe for success I think it was really
useful to just look at what you need in
the different part of the game what you
should focus on
so uh today's this is just gonna be like
a light we're just gonna touch on a lot
of different things and then in the
bottom of the screen there will be a
little a little text when it says where
you can go to see more perfect and
you've got a link to your channel where
you you go into real detail on each of
these so
um do check out boneless dota's Channel
if you'd like to find out more about
this but today we're like we're doing a
wider snapshot so what I really like
about how you've structured this is that
you've got your opening hand which is
the early game you've got your early to
mid game section and you've got your mid
to late game section and I think it's
really important that the strategy
changes over that time period so are you
ready to begin sure okay so let's start
with the opening hand
yeah basically the first thing this is
like a list of priority so the first
thing I'm looking for is just money
income and capital so before I look at
any of the other stuff I just want to
see how can I get the biggest engine
like here and now in my opening hand and
can I get some card draw to Cobble with
this and then also once we have that we
can begin uh looking at some of the
other things so for example if you go to
yeah your default strategy is the engine
strategy then just build out as much and
as fast as the opening a hand it doesn't
have to be even if you're going for the
terror for me strategy you still want to
look at do I have any make a Critic
production do I have any character I
mean capital is situational if you're
going like for the fast game but if it
could still we are talking about the
opening handset nevertheless it's still
like good to notice if you have one or
some of the stuff that's right perfect
okay
Yeah so basically in the beginning you
will need the money income so on the on
the top of the screen here we have all
the stuff that's like good for building
your engine and it's like like you're
talking about I'm mostly enjoying greedy
games so definitely all of this stuff
like titanium production steel
production make a creative production
all of this stuff that really helps you
build card helps you buy cars during the
game
on the bottom of the screen
uh it says if it's in your interest to
close the game you can also build your
engine with heat and TR
but like I said even if if you even if
you're building your engine this way you
still need a little bit of money income
to actually glue it together if that
makes sense you can't just absolutely
expect to win the game you need a little
bit of income yeah regardless of your
strategy money's got to be there tell me
which uh expansions are we talking about
here is this just the base game or are
we also referring to colonies
I think all of these tips here uh
they're good no matter how many
expansions you play with but basically
for the most part we are also talking
about pre-alert we're also talking about
colonies so all expansions except for
turmoil I would say but these are more
like General ideas of things you should
look for so even if you don't have all
the expansions this will still be useful
excellent thank you okay so we're moving
into card draw now and there are three
cards that you're suggesting we always
keep almost
yes
um The Only Exception would be actually
we'll gotta get to the exceptions in
just a second but yeah before we get to
that these three are just Stellar card
Pro cards I think and the the reason
these are so good is because these are
like effects so when something happens
you get a card and these are just a
little bit Superior compared to just a
flat flat cap that just gives you a card
once per generation like as an action
card okay so you see these take them
that's Mars University Olympus
conference and spin-off department now
there are some other cards that you
should keep most of the time
yeah I mean Capital cars in general
um if you're going for the greedy Club
strategy or just if you're going for the
long game really then you definitely
take all the card Pro you can get if you
are going Force like all the non-cities
or all in on on the terraforming
strategy then you then you are not
keeping that many draw cards but even
then these three are just so good that
even then I would still consider to keep
this but it's not a given that you keep
Capital if you're going all in on
terraforming for example
perfect okay when would you not keep
card draw cards in
yes there are a few examples like in the
late game some card broadcast they are
simply just too expensive if they only
draw you like one or two cards
so for example we have this card here
Inventus Guild it's a it's it's not one
of the better cards it's sort of one of
the weaker cards because it's very
expensive for what it gives you but if
you're playing the greedy game and you
get this in the beginning of game you're
of course still very happy but let's say
we're on the second to last generation
even the last generation then you would
not really take this card
so because what is it giving you it's
like it cost you nine plus three foot
card plus three for the actual card that
you're buying with the car so for 15
Mega credits you only get one card if
you play this in the last iteration so
that's usually not worth it okay that
makes sense any other thoughts on card
draw here
yeah if you have a lot of if you have
plenty of good cards in your hand
already maybe you don't need more cards
but then we again back to like if you
hand this a stack with with really good
curves then it makes sense you wouldn't
really have to invest in getting even
more carbs if you're just happy with
playing the stuff you already have in
your hand
and number three ironically if you're
um
yeah and number three ironically if your
engine is bad it is sometimes hard to
keep card blocker as this is just a
luxury you cannot afford right now so
we're back to this I I mentioned in one
of my episodes that you need a balance
of both to make this work you need a
balance of both money income and card
draw if you have like a million cap drop
but you have no money income it's not
good but if you have on the other hand
if you have a lot of money income but
you have no card though cut wrong then
you're still gonna struggle like
everything in life balance is good yeah
especially when it comes to one income
versus Capital you need a balance of
both to make it work right and if you
hit that sweet spot where you're just
maximizing everything then you go to God
mode yeah exactly
excellent okay so if you're all in on
cities or terraforming what are we
looking at here
yes uh so so this is the starting hand I
have for example so in this case
my hand is just stacked with City
Synergy you you might not see it
immediately but we have the ecology
experts Prelude plus kelp farming so
there's a loan in Fall plant production
then we got even more clear plant
production in the hand and we got
fastest we got the early settlement that
I'm choosing to keep even though this
Prelude is kind of bad but in this case
it's okay so in this case
I wouldn't keep Development Center for
for two reasons first of all I don't
really have energies to support it like
if I went for power generation it could
be okay but the thing is if you're just
all in on terraforming on this in this
case if you're all in them cities
because this hand is so good when it
comes to cities then it's like you're
just so focused on doing this one thing
that you don't really need to actually
get any more card draw if that makes
sense you're already like like awesome
in this direction so there's no need to
yeah you don't need to double up
that's right I mean you could but but in
in a lot of cases it's just a
it's just not worth it in this case for
example I wouldn't keep this Development
Center mm-hmm
good let's move now to the Synergy and
you're going to focus on the colony
Synergy here
yes so what I'm looking for especially
so yeah this is only if you play with
colonies obviously but if you are
playing with colonies I just look for a
little bit of colony Synergy because
it's very strong so here are the
colonies and like as a rule to begin the
game it's very good if you can get some
of these zeros Luna Triton Pluto just to
get some resources get some card draw is
it really what you're looking for in the
opening hand and then of course if you
also need to to get some energy
production you could go for all pair
Kalisto if you want a terraform
obviously Ganymede IO and then if we go
to the next slide
but but basically all of these cards
here uh this is like a lot of the the
Synergy that I'm talking about so for
example we've got standard projects then
our standard technology then all of a
sudden just buying a colony is for 14
and that that by itself is really good
that's right and if we got a little bit
more of this stuff a little bit more of
these cards here then we already have a
decent amount of colony Synergy and I
think colonies are really good so if you
have just a little bit of this stuff I
think you should seriously consider
building colonies it really feels like
you just need to take a measure of what
you're being offered find that Synergy
and then start to stack or amplify that
one strategy yes these are definitely
about just finding finding the best
synergies in your hand any of my cards
playing well together stuff like this
okay so we've actually taken into
account the cooperation yeah right we
got some great cards most of the time
these are sort of General Car General
use cards and then situational cards
yeah it's uh
um
usually it's like this but it's it's not
like a given you know but I I would say
that all the cards to the right usually
I'm very happy when I see those but but
the two cards to the left those are very
situational those are more like for the
mid to late game to be honest right okay
very good and we'll move on to discounts
now
yes so uh discount is definitely also
something you want to look at like uh
I'm I'm often talking about that you
need money income you need card draw
especially if you want to go the greedy
game but actually what you need more
than most is Card discount Plus card
draw this is actually way better than
bigger credit production right if you
can stack this a little bit and you can
have a lot of cardboard a lot of carb
discount this is very very good yeah if
you don't need money to buy these or you
need less money then that's much more
effective let's take a look more at card
drawing Card discount here then yeah so
for example like what I'm talking about
this is the third craft hand I made and
it's just to emphasize like like all
this discount you can get and all the
capital you can get this is like it's so
amazingly strong so yeah
all right let's turn our attention to
heat production how much is heat
production worth to you in the early
game
yeah I would say hit production in the
early game is generally worth five Mega
credit but this is like only from a
street like engine building and VP point
of view like but the thing about heat
production the most important thing is
that it's kind of bad unless it's in
your interest to actually close the game
if you want to close the game then it's
immediately better so it's up to eight
Mega credits or something it's hard to
say but but yeah I hit production by
itself is kind of underwhelming yeah but
if you want to close the game heat
production and especially with a with a
hip heat combo then it's really good
very nice okay and Heat's okay if you do
have a combo though
yeah heat is good if you have a combo so
this is what I'm talking about in the
early game when I'm looking for heat
Synergy some of this stuff would be
really good for example if you have the
other day I just had a game where I had
a bunch of heat production and then I
randomly picked up insulation and that's
perfect because now I can just pump up
the heat as much as I want
and then I have this insurance if that
makes sense to just go for installation
when the heat is like maxed right you
can also do it differently if you want
to play more greedy you can just make a
bunch of view production and use
insulation immediately
but so you get more control over your
mega credit production then yeah heat
production it just gets a lot better if
you have a little bit of synergy to go
with it that's really what I'm trying to
say here
okay
and we've got a formula here
yeah so it what I was talking about like
if you have exactly 80 production then
you could kind of see that it's like
worth one it's like one TR per
generation and if we save one TR to be
eight which I do then it's basically
eight Mega credit production so when you
look at the best way this way it's
actually kind of good
um so but but this of course then we
also have to take into account then you
need to have a plan B for when the heat
is maxed because otherwise this math
just falls apart so if you have like
heliana installation okay I'll take a
contract or something or if heat is the
last parameter to close well then we can
say this then we can say that one
Victory Point per generation or one TR
per generation that's exactly eight Mega
credit production so it gets a little
bit better if you think about it this
way yeah okay
and you've got another cool combo here
yeah so uh like if we got extreme cold
funkers together with either regular
eaters or GHC producing bacteria this is
also like one free TR per generation so
that's also like eight Mega credit
production if you want to look at it
that way so yeah that's also good okay
nice okay and we're moving on to number
three are my cards supporting a strategy
now so what strategies are we talking
about
yeah and basically these are the
strategies I'm covering on my channel
but the
um basically the most important ones
would be the field to do with the
terraform or just the terraforming
strategy if you want to follow that the
greedy cut strategy and also the city
strategy these are like I want to look
for cars that actually support this so
for example if I have a bunch of cities
energetic cards if I'm fastest or
something then of course I'm looking for
more cards to go with the cap or the
city strategy or if I have a lot of
engine a lot of card draw I might just
go in this direction to go for greedy
game or if I had like the game I was
just talking about if I just have a lot
of heat production and stuff like this
well maybe I go for the for the for the
terriform again yeah this is like a yoga
for sale is commented the other day that
he's he's go to strategy it's actually
this mid game strategy so uh I just
wanted to include this as well uh
because uh it actually makes a lot of
sense so so what he does is actually he
he terraforms a fair amount but he keeps
a little bit of card draw but not too
much and then he just wants to close the
game exactly at The Sweet Spot before
the greedy guy is about to beat him but
then he still has a lot of points to
actually beat the other terraformers so
it's a it's a risky Road you would have
to be a genius like a jack of foxelius
to actually make this work but it is a
valid strategy I think it makes sense
yeah okay and these are your three main
strategies you would focus on then yeah
we're still talking about the opening
hands so definitely the strategy two
three four the like cards that support
these strategies there's definitely also
what I'm looking for involving here okay
very nice
so the as you can see like the filthy
dirty terraforming that's beautiful
that's a short game the car strategy is
suited for the long game and then the
city strategy is overall also it can
always work they see the strategy yeah
very nice okay
all right so cards uh the dirty
terraformer might like
uh it's just this stuff uh it's uh
normally I would say that if you have
regular Adidas or GFC producing bacteria
you would kind of need to have a card
like the one the combo we just showed
before
um the cold fungus to actually go with
that but uh yeah and and you need a
particular corporation to make these
work
no it's just these are just examples of
what you might want to look for if
you're going for the terraforming
strategy Omni is like the the
corporation that most people like
connecting with a terraforming strategy
gotcha okay very good and you could
terraform a lot based on your opening
hand or if you realize your opponent has
a better engine you can start
terraforming to close the game yeah
exactly that's right
so
yeah and so we've talked about this as
well the terraforming strategy is better
in the bigger games four or five player
games but in the shorter games uh you
want to close the game out uh a little
quicker
yes so it's two or three player games
they're all in terraforming strategy it
just almost never works oh it doesn't
work right so yeah yeah but but in the
mid game in the mid game strategy like
like like I talked about before that can
still work into play games and also
notably I'm just talking about the the
strategy wages right from the beginning
just go all in on zero for me this is
what I'm talking about that's it's
entirely reasonable even in a two-player
game to see to see like in the middle of
the game all right my opponent actually
has more luck when it comes to engine
and capital maybe I should now start to
close the game that's entirely
reasonable that's right I'm just talking
about the opening hand you'll want to go
all in terraforming you cannot do that
in two or three player games it's just
not gonna work I'll link two or two
videos we've done one on each of these
uh your two two three player game you
scored like 278 and in your four to five
player game it was much smaller score
because you closed it quickly so I'll
put the links to those there so okay so
can we look at what defines a greedy
card strategy then
yes real quick first of all you need a
lot of cardboard cards you need like a
bigger hand size than you would normally
have it's not uncommon that you have
twin cards when you go for the greedy
cast reality and you also need a huge
engine a lot of money can come slide we
just saw and also you don't want to
terraform too much like if you act
actually yourself want to make sure that
the game drags out you can just make an
effort to not terraform too much so what
you want to do is identify the last
parameter to close and then you should
be really careful before you terraform
that it's still worth it if you get like
a bonus or something but just you should
really be careful if you want to go to a
greedy late game you should be careful
to terraform
and then all of a sudden also we want
cut discount and like I talked about
before cup discount Plus Card Draw that
is really powerful especially for these
long greedy games
and then I'm also looking for resource
amplifiers and victory Point amplifiers
so yeah this is really the stuff I'm
looking for when I'm going for the
greedy costume
excellent okay and some more strategies
here are we focusing in on the city
strategy
yeah so the city strategy and and this
is still like the opening hand so in the
in the city strategy I I'm just looking
for cards that support the city strategy
you know there's a lot of City energetic
cards
[Music]
so what kind of synergies are we looking
at then
yeah definitely just stuff that makes
your your city be cheaper or best of all
if you could get immigrant City Martian
rails or fastest that's really good to
begin with because this is actually
increase your mega credit production
when you play cities in the early game
right but other than that we can have
there's a ton but but if you want to
build your engine with cities you kind
of need this but otherwise you can just
uh if you have City cards instead of
just using the standard project that's a
lot better but then like for example if
you have pits and your fastest you just
slam down pets and you don't have to go
for cities right away but along the
during the game you just build a lot of
cities and the pets is gonna absolutely
make some points for you
okay so let's move on to Milestones and
planning which ones we aim for
yeah so also in my opening hand I don't
think you should it should not be like a
big part of your opening hand but you
can like have this in the back of your
head you should still like plan which
Milestones to go for
okay so in the early game you should
definitely have milestones in mind and
you should always aim to get one of the
Milestones that naturally is coming to
you on your way so Milestones are less
important to two or three player games
but they are more important for fire
player games and the reason for this is
like in two three player games it's this
course is just so much higher so the
Milestones are not that important in
four to five player games this course
gonna be a lot lower so the five Victory
point you can get from Milestone can
really make a difference
but the yeah what I was saying before
you really you you have to go for the
Milestone that naturally fits your game
that that comes naturally to you because
if you're like all right I'm playing on
the base map I'm going for Maya and then
you see you have photo Space Heaven you
have early settlement all right that's
two cities and then just build a
standard project City to get the last
one yes congratulations you got the
media but then you also lost the game so
right okay so you tend towards getting
the Milestone that suits your build
rather than building your build to focus
on a milestone yeah exactly if it is a
five player game you know then it could
be okay to just like like make a couple
of sub-optimal play just together a
milestone but generally speaking I would
much rather get the Milestone that
naturally fits my game that's right okay
so let's look at number five here can
you afford to keep good cards for later
yeah exactly so this is the reason this
is number five is like this is exactly
what I want to look at when I've looked
at the four other things in my opening
hand and the reason for this is when I
have an idea of what I want to do in the
first generation then I can actually
calculate how much Mega credits do I
have left over and can I actually afford
to actually keep good cards for later so
it's something you might consider but
just remember it does come with a cost
like keeping greedy cards that you're
not gonna spend right now you can
actually tank your your hand your
economy a little bit to keep that in
your opening hand but it is worth it
sometimes for sure nice there's a there
are some benefits to it but there is a
cost so let's look at resource
amplifiers yes exactly so we got for
example resource amplifiers it could be
some of this stuff like especially if
we're still talking about the early game
it makes sense that you would like keep
some of these because some of these
cards can actually help to build your
engine even more so this is definitely
the class I'm looking for in the opening
hand
excellent
okay and plant amplifiers
yes also I think plan production is
really good but generally speaking you
want to to get this in the in the early
to mid game so if I have a lot of good
if I have some good planned cards uh it
just could be these amplifiers could
also just be playing production cars in
general if I can get away with it
without taking my economy I could also
consider keeping some of these in my
opinion
oh okay so you were talking about the
Jovian strategy so what are the Jovian
amplifiers
yeah the German amplifiers the German is
a set collection of this game so we got
these four cards that says you get one
EP or well terraforming uh if you're a
terraforming enemy but basically you get
one VP for each jobian you have a plate
so the these cards are a very good late
game usually you play these in the last
generation it's a fire mining Industries
because that gives a lot of engine as
well so you could play that earlier but
if you're keeping these cards in your
opening hand then it's like it's a card
that you're creeping in your opening
hand that you're not playing until the
late game so you have to be kinda sure
that you really want to go for jovians
because otherwise it's not worth it but
that being said Jovian amplifiers if
you're going for Joe wins it could be so
strong that it might actually be worth
keeping in your opening hand if you see
this wow okay but you got to go all in
yeah if you're keeping job in amplifiers
you have to go for jovians there's no
way around it it's kind of the same with
these cards here these are like the
green tags and VP cards so to speak you
can compare these to the German
amplifiers a little bit if you're going
for green tags once again these are also
more suited for the mid to late game
strategy
um but but these cards are just very
powerful so it could be worth to keep in
the early game as well yeah 7vp for the
large Convoy and venusian animals
yeah that's uh it's not gonna be this
like all the time but if you think about
it it with the large Convoy if you have
an animal card where the car animals are
worth one Victory Point per animal and
you get four animals and there's two of
each report on the card and there's also
water so that's why it comes to seven oh
wow and the news in animal I just I just
put like my my estimation on this so I
think it's not often that the Venus go
to 18 but when it does I always get a
lot of value from the new scene animals
but once again only in the mid to late
game probably okay so what if you're
doing the science cards
yeah if I get some of these cards
obviously I mean you you know the
feeling you you're seeing some of these
cards and you maybe you don't quite
complain in the first generation or
maybe you don't you still needing like
maybe one or two more science tags but
these cards are just so powerful that if
you get some of these cards on your
opening hand and you have an idea all
right I can probably fulfill the science
requirement then these cards are
definitely also Worth to keep in the
opening hand
really okay so now we're moving on to
the second portion of the video and
that's the early to mid game so uh why
don't we start with the resource
amplifier
yeah we already looked at this actually
but the definitely this is the time
where I would play this stuff so and
it's it's it's a all of these costs by
Nature are very situational so it's not
always you're gonna get good value from
these but that being said if you can
make this aligned with your game it can
be extremely powerful so for example if
you have cocktail and you already have a
lot of Earth tags it could be like a
huge boost to your engine the same with
Like Satellites and lunar mining like
all of these cards here if it makes
sense for your game if you have a lot of
these tags played then it can be very
powerful for sure absolutely and we've
got some rules here so if you have a
resource amplifying card like insects
cartel or satellites you should maximize
the value of the card by playing as many
of the tags as possible before playing
the amplifier
what are we talking about there
yeah so for example if we got the cartel
and you have a lot of Earth attacks on
your hand then it makes sense you
definitely want to play as many Earth
tags before you actually play the cartel
okay just to maximize the benefit there
yeah exactly
but they also remember that this is like
production so you have to be really
careful here actually because there's
also this aspect of remember production
is better the earlier you get it so it's
it's kind of a balancing act if that
makes sense you kind of want to maximize
the efficiency of your car but there's
also this thing that re like resource
production is just better the earlier
you can get it down so it's a yeah you
really have to think about it absolutely
and what's a steady deadly combo you've
got for us here yeah it's like this is
like a perfect example of of how you can
like really go all in on just getting
like a resource amplifier like for
example medical lab is in the vanilla
set so if you get medical lab you have a
lot of building tags you get a strong
medical lab and then you can just slam
down a robotic Workforce to just double
medical lab it can be very powerful you
can generate a huge engine like this
easy win
all right all right so in early to mid
game you you need to decide on a
strategy and go for it so how or when do
you do this
yeah so
um basically in your opening hand like
you can have an idea what you're going
for but it's not until like a few
Generations in you're kind of you're
gonna look at what everyone else is
doing you're gonna look what's
synergizing in your hand maybe I picked
up a lot of Sydney Synergy since the
opening hand so this is the part of the
game where you really have to put your
mind all right what what's my strategy
actually gonna be today
right you might want to actually mine
for particular cards or that type of
thing yeah so so you kind of have to go
for like this is the last chance for you
to just pinpoint yourself in into a
strategy and just commit to that
basically okay and you also need to
decide shorter long game here I assume
yeah exactly if like the rule of thumb
if you're going for the greedy long game
if you go out the cards and they've got
the greedy engine you want to go for the
long game
and on the other hand if your opponent
got the quick green curves and the
greedy engine then you want to maybe
close the game a bit sooner because the
greedy players always gonna make the
most points in the last few Generations
so if you let it drag out that's
definitely to the greedy guys Advantage
okay in the previous
um early phase we looked at what
milestones we wanted to eye up now we're
talking about actually purchasing them
yes so in the early submit game this is
where you buy Milestones as well and
yeah like we talked about Milestones I
mean they're really good when everything
is said and done to get five victory
points for eight Mega credits that's of
course very good so you should always
aim to get one of these and maybe more
of these if you can get away with it and
like we mentioned they are of course
better in in five four five player games
in five player games it is actually just
a race straight up race to get to the
Milestones as soon as possible but uh
okay and so if your economy can handle
it this is number 10 uh you should pick
up the victory Point amplifiers but
don't play them why is that yes
I mean this is like in the same line as
you could pick up good cards for later
in your opening hand this is like it's a
little bit less risky to actually pick
them up now here in their little mid
game because now you haven't grieved
your opening hand so much by doing this
but like we mentioned these adjobian
amplifiers for example they can be very
powerful in the late game so I'm
definitely looking to pick up some of
these VP amplifiers at this point
especially in the mid game but I'm not
actually gonna play them like for
example if the Jovian amplifiers you
don't want to play until the last
generation except for mining Industries
okay
and if we're looking at the green versus
Joven amplifiers
yeah this is also something all of these
cars here basically they're really good
to pick up in the mid game and if you if
we're talking about like decomposers
ecological Zone herbivores maybe also
play them in the mid game because they
can actually stack up a little bit but
but generally speaking most of these
cards should be played like in the late
game but but that doesn't mean you can't
pick them up now this is the part of the
game where I would pick up these cards
because they can be very powerful and
give you a lot of points later
okay yeah all right so what do you do
with plant production when when should
you be doing this
yeah I would definitely get playing
production in the mid game I think mid
game is like this The Sweet Spot we went
to get plant production uh the thing is
at the very least you need to build like
a little bit of money income a little
bit of money engine before you can
actually justify going for uh plants uh
so I I think mid game is a good time to
go for plant production because
basically plant production is not a way
to build your engine it's really not
it's basically a way to get a lot of VP
so in the mid to late game this is where
you really want to benefit from having a
lot of greeneries so by this logic I
think it makes a lot of sense to build
plant production in the mid game or in
the early to mid game but at the very
least after you have some money income
growing
okay
this is a fun little graphic plants are
mainly victory points so we should think
about them that way
yeah definitely uh yeah this is what I
was saying like
if you think about it it's really hard
to get a plant down in the early game
and even if you do it it's only one TR
and one TR is like one Mega credit
production so for engine building
purposes plants and greeneries it's not
not good for building your engine so I
think it's very good to just get plain
production in the early to mid game
especially in the mid game and then you
can benefit from uh getting a lot of
greeneries down and getting a lot of VP
in the mid to late game with friends
okay
and what are we looking at here with
plant amplifiers
yeah once again the planned amplifies uh
of course really good if you want to go
for plant production these are
definitely cards I'm happy to see all of
these carbs are very good it's not often
I get a nice worms down because it's not
often this card actually is worth it but
all the other cards here just Stella
they're very good if you're going for
plant production
okay and you also should play the late
game plant cards too
yeah I just wanted to mention that even
though I say that flame production
should be played on the mid game maybe
even early to mid game of course if you
see some of these late game plan cards
you of course still want to play these
because these are very good the thing is
it's kind of balanced in a way so even
though that they you need six water you
need like a lot of heat temperature to
actually play some of these cars they're
just so aggressively stated that it's
still worth to play it later on so these
are actually very good cards you should
definitely look for these cards in the
middle again okay we'll keep the eyes
open for them so now we're looking at
the floater Synergy yeah so floras is
definitely a thing I want to look at
also in the mid to late game because
this is where we have now in the game so
uh and the thing is I think Florida's
Synergy and could generate a lot of VP
and this is why I think it makes a lot
of sense to play these in the mid to
late game
okay so there's a few exceptions though
yeah there's a few exceptions that are
better for the early game but generally
speak actually pointed them out here so
like if we're talking about uh aerial
mappers
urea tables I have no idea how to
pronounce this Titan Shadows Titan
floating airpad local shading Apple
collectors some of these cars are really
good in the early game it's a bit
awkward to play Titan shadows in the
early game but just because it's so
expensive but at the end of the day it
is titanium production so it could make
sense and you might be thinking Admiral
collectors and stuff like this well why
is this really good but the thing is
this is a
there's a colonies card so if you're
playing with colonies you also need to
get three energy production so this card
Admiral collectors is actually very good
to play in the first generation at the
start of the game because you you just
automatically get three energy
production because you can make one
Flora into three energy okay wow
tell me what are what are the five
things you can do with the floaters
yeah definitely I I just boiled it down
to five things that I thought is really
good with Florida so first of all if you
go for floaters you really should look
for German lanterns and floating Habs
because these are the two Florida cards
in the game where the floaters are worth
two uh or one Victory point for two
floaters so so and there's so many cars
in this game that I can actually put
floors onto another car so this is why I
think these cars are really good also
you can look for combo so some of the
compost for example we got startopolis
enforced Chris precipitation
precipitation yeah precipitation yeah I
have no idea how to pronounce this
character yeah that's okay you're here
to help me English is your second
language so you help me with strategy
and I'll help you with the English it's
great all right that's the deal
but yeah if you look for some of these
compost also this is a really good one
hydrogen to Venus and floating Habs this
is something you really want to play in
the late game because if you think about
hydrogen to Venus it's like just a half
of a jovian amplifier especially if you
use it in conjunction with floating Habs
so if you could get these two crafts
together it can be really strong in the
late game it can generate a lot of
loaders to your floating hips
and number three you aim to get
hoverlord and venue file what is this
yes oh the oh the Milestone and the
award okay yeah exactly so if you are
playing with floaters in generally
speaking then it makes a lot of sense
that you go for these two because it
just goes hand in hand yeah it does
number four
you're aiming for a card with a Venus
requirement like videos animals yeah
exactly the news and animals is the big
it's a big one I'm talking about but the
all the other that love a few walls are
like Venus in insects and a few others
but basically all of these cards are not
the impactful one this is definitely the
most impactful one if you can ever
manage to get Venus to 18 and play
videos and animals and you still have
time to play a lot of science text the
value can get quite insane in other
games where this card just gave me more
than 20 victory points it can get quite
nuts oh wow and the fifth time the fifth
way you can use floaters
yeah yeah the fifth way you can use
fluores is just by playing them by
themselves like it's not you don't have
to go for a combo I just wanted to
mention that a lot of these floaters are
actually quite good by themselves just
the cards you don't like you don't
really have to to have a lot of combos
to actually justify going for floors a
lot of these cards are just solid by
themselves
okay
nice okay moving on to the green tag
synergy
yeah so at the green tax energy is
that's actually where you just uh
you know you don't want to tear up on
too much but you just want to collect
bucks that's really worth it about so
this is also some stuff you want to look
at in the mid to late game and once
we're talking about the green tax
energies of course I just have to give
an honorable mention to beat Industries
because as soon as we have floaters or
animals of any kind these three cards
here those are just very very good yeah
man I have to give an honorable nod to
the pun meeting the demands for high
protein foods that's terrible yeah
exactly yeah that's really good all
right so we've got a deadly combo here
ants yeah Venetian insects and these two
cards extreme cold fungus and bacto
viral research yeah exactly in the mid
to late game these are the combos you
want to be looking for because these
combos can give you like what is it like
depending what cup we're talking about
we're talking about a dream called Focus
it's like one point every generation
colossal you can also use the card by
itself so it's like one and a half Point
per generation
so this can be very good in the mid to
late game for sure this is why card draw
you told me in our strategy video that
card draw is really important to you and
now I see why because you're looking for
particular combos to to put together so
just increasing your odds of of hitting
those so yeah definitely large fish
yeah yeah that's another very good combo
so so it's like it makes sense right
because we're talking about the mid to
late game and green tax green tax energy
in general that's also really good when
we go when we like playing the long game
playing one of the greedy the mid game
strategy or the greedy car strategy so
when you have a lot of card run a lot of
engine you can pick a lot of these
cities
what's it called like green Synergy
cards uh we could call it so you can
generate a lot of points by doing this
so this is definitely stuff I'm looking
for in the mid to late game for sure
okay yeah here's an example this
actually the game we covered on your
channel this is an example of just how
many points you can actually create some
green tags yes like green sex energy you
can get quite insane so it's definitely
uh a thing you should look for in my
opinion it's just as good as Jovian
Empires maybe even better but oh very
nice
okay moving on to the awards section yes
so the water kind of weird uh generally
I think it's really dangerous to start
these too early but the thing is they
they start cheap right the first the
world only cost eight and then it goes
to 14 and then 20. but I think the first
one you could justify to do that in the
early mid game but then you have to be
very sure that you're actually winning
this award because even then it's not
worth it like you're spending eight but
if you're not winning that award or if
you're not even getting second of that
award that's just money out the window
and when it comes to the mid game and
the late game I think this is the part
where you should look at the one that
costs 14 and the one that costs 20. so
like even even in the last iteration am
I not even like even consider the last
award before the last generation it kind
of depends on the game of course but but
I just wanted to to make the point that
it's not like it's not that important uh
to to get these as soon as possible
because it can be really dangerous if
your opponents are actually taking them
okay yeah that makes sense so
um back to Jovian amplifiers now
yes so uh we are in the late game now we
are probably maybe even the last
generation so this is the point of the
game where I definitely just want to
play my German amplifiers and stuff like
this so all of these you want to play in
yeah
let's shift now to uh the sort of late
mid to late game what are we looking at
here with Advanced ecosystems
yes so this is the last point of the
menu so now we're talking about the last
generation and it's very important that
you actually like spend these cards use
them in the last generation the cards
that only give VP if they give nothing
else except for VP you should play them
in the last generation
uh it's just it's just the most
efficient way to do it excellent so that
covers the opening hand the early to mid
game and the mid to late game when
you're just slamming down those victory
points hopefully all of our viewers out
there get more victories after watching
your video and just a reminder they can
go check out your channel if they'd like
to see more of this so thank you so much
for joining us today boneless we
appreciate your expertise
yeah thanks for having me
get out there get gaming be legendary
thanks so much for your time